Lucid dreaming is being conscientiously aware that you're dreaming. So, how can
we lucid dream? Well, Steven L'Burg, an expert in the field, says that lucid
dreamers actually develop a mindset that allows them to recognize that they're
dreaming. And once they recognize that they're dreaming they can actually
change the content of their dream.
&gt;&gt; That's right and proponents of lucid dreaming tell a variety of benefits. For
example, in one pilot study, they looked at an individual who had nightmares.
And the idea was, if you could teach the person to lucid dream and become aware
when they're having a nightmare, they could actually change the outcome of that
dream. In this example, the person did actually experience fewer nightmares,
although the mechanism of action, or how it happened still remains unclear.
There are lots of great tips and tricks on how to engage lucid dreaming, and I
really suggest that you try. I myself have been able to lucid dream on a few
occasions. It usually happens when I have this dream that I'm chewing glass.
For some reason, I'm able to realize that I wouldn't chew glass in real life.
And it's at this point that I usually wake up, however some people have been
able to lucid dream such that they're able to change the content and even fly
away.
&gt;&gt; That's really cool Susan. I'm really glad you don't eat glass when you're
awake. &gt;&gt; [LAUGH]
&gt;&gt; That's good but now that I have you here why don't we move on to the drugs and
consciousness part of this lesson since that is area of expertise?
&gt;&gt; That sounds great Lauren, but first we have to say, or define what is a drug.